hey guys i am just mcdonald it is a 16th
of july today and you actually into
gamespot news first up it's a good thing
that we've got an open world zelda game
on the way for wii u because it sounds
like hyrule warriors will not be the
zelda game you're looking for according
to our very own Tom mcshay Hyrule
warriors is very much a plowing down
enemy sort of title and if you're into
that then you'll be good to go but for
die-hard Hyrule fans it's missing that
Zelda flavor there's musical cues from
the beloved old school games and some of
the same weapons and enemies make an
appearance like bombs and dad unger but
this seems like it'll be one for dynasty
Warriors fans and not so much so the
devotees next up it seems that the
popularity of digital distribution is
not a threat to brick-and-mortar stores
after all at least that's according to
gamestop the company's president Tony
Bartel told VentureBeat that in fact
most of their digital revenue comes from
their real-world stores explaining the
console digital is predominantly things
like Xbox Live PlayStation Network and
nintendo eshop cards then there's
downloadable content which is fast
growing in the console digital Bartel
went on to say that dlc season passes
particularly those be ubisoft games do
very well in their physical stores and
apparently thirty percent of people who
grabbed watchdogs also got themselves
the twenty-dollar season pass if you've
been holding out for bungie's destiny
then you'll probably want to know that
its beta is open for ps3 and ps4 users
tomorrow not only that but you can grab
the mobile companion app today if you so
choose the app conveys the 3d version of
your character where you can change
armor monitor your inventory and access
the compendium of Destiny's law you'll
also be able to use the app to access
forums groups and the latest news and
updates about destiny don't worry too
much if you're an Xbox household go
since it's only another week's worth of
waiting before you get the beta 2
although if you want to guarantee that
you'll get a spot in the destiny beta
you'll need to pre-order yourself a copy
finally today Microsoft Phil Spencer is
said that the xbox has always struggled
in Japan
he's came for the launch of the xbox one
in the region in September the typically
Nintendo driven region has has sony
admitting they're doing only okay there
as now Spencer has weighed in with we
will be in Japan in September Japan
hasn't always been the easiest market
for us will be good to launch and be at
tokyo game show Sony's Andrew house site
is that the main reason the ps4 is
struggling in Japan is due to the lack
of content created by Japanese devs to
appeal to the local market on the other
side of the fence Microsoft have said
that they have burst party games being
developed in Japan and they're
optimistic about the xbox one's launch
there for today's question of the day
let me know down in the comments if you
prefer buying games in store or
digitally and why that is it from me
today i'll be back same time and place
to mobile until then we sort of have
yourself a good day